welcome to this video the gambler no I
never played this guy you call yourself
the gambling and then you play this
opening okay the London system how
exciting is it going to get this game at
least I'm going to flake wikia don't
want to lose on timing and someone was
to place this opening and then just
shuffles there is this kind of player
relief they did they play that and never
play any active move just try to win on
time and then sometimes we work
indefinitely so I'm just completing my
my usual my standard setup here and hope
that this is okay let's do that trade
our stuff here Knight to d7 44 very
decent Hedgehog now my plan is to go for
b5 and the long run and I'm not going to
overlook this checkmate yeah he wants to
trade everything if it was possible he
would trade pieces twice yeah but once
they are traded they they don't come
back okay b5 next or what exactly Bishop
takes age 6 this is his idea and Bishop
takes d6 okay so quince is 6 first on
this was my original idea with quincy
aid okay g5 now is bad due to h form in
so g6
preventing bishop age 6 hmm h5 I guess
ok let's see that I get this counter
play going on the queenside I don't
really see myself getting checkmated
here but maybe i am rook g3 Queen h5 or
whatever whatever is the idea I don't
know Bishop g7 is possible at almost any
given moment g-form I didn't think about
that one but it's very it's very much on
ice I understand ok covering age 5
so Bishop g7 area to get get rid of this
situation yep come on
okay I can take a five now if i want i
guess i want the pawn the only thing i
have to heavy aware of quincy three
check or something at at one point yeah
here he goes here he goes is the idea
takes rook e8 Queenie aid check there
and I'm losing the rockin okay this is
the kind of thing how we can do such a
game hmm if I take with the rukon defy
of however this is just this is working
right she takes the check check and now
i can take on g4 i can take on g4 yeah
this should be good starting starting
with the move and go from there what am
i doing now Queen Queen move on like E
55 is also good probably closing things
Quincy 7 a queen d7 I mean is a move now
hmm
27 does a bit annoying I can go look
aged 8 26 25 there is no checkmate I'm
not checkmating him okay ma'am so then
just keep keep material it's um it's two
pawns already check for Luke h3 f I
didn't see that one hmm I didn't see
that he has rook h3 that's that's a
shame okay and look II five he's got F
form mmm and f6 is kind of kind of
uncomfortable and he has a check on a
seven
yeah that really was not ideal check
check
I wonder if he goes f3 should I trade
rooks online more negative 5 he might be
able to check sacrifice on g6 so let's
do this end game this was my original
intention so let's just go for it
going for be three that's them that's
the right square check check Queen D for
possibly but I have to move relatively
quickly check check
King what is the idea Kings you five or
what I don't see it
check
bloody time
it will be difficult due to the time
eight seconds you only have to be
content with the draw if fact if I get
it check check check check dra Alfred
check oh yeah that was hot too it was
really not great I should win this with
this time but now Jack Queen B 2 is a
pretty good yeah Queen B 2 is very
simple very simple this is Beth tech
technical play a to this is just so
simple I'm keeping the long diagonal in
check so that he doesn't have a check
and I'm just pushing through he has
absolutely no more this wins of course
yeah why not this is not the case of how
quick do I win even though when I went
like this it was clear that added that
I'm accepting the draw here with Queen
Queen B 1 even here black wins with
Queen whatever 23 okay and not that 123
or something like that just have to keep
the pawn I wanted to basically force
this that he has to go for the check cm
he could have one on time which she did
not do physically check yeah of course a
draw is really not really not the result
that check that I wanted here I think
this was was quite okay how I played it
also here this is 0 this is an ok ok em
try a transformation into this tattoo
this winning a game here the Queen end
game with the Queen supporting from
behind is really a pretty
straightforward win
it just got to go to be tricky due to
the time strange yes this has this
checks all the time okay well thank you